you wouldn't believe it I mean you know
a suit of armor $64,000 Rolex watch it
was like incredibly rare tons of really
expensive jul 2013 10 has created a
monopoly around selling people's lost
luggage how do you hear about this and
tell us a little bit about it soare
founder Sam actually came across this
company he likes to research weird
business models and kind of boring
companies that are doing interesting
things in the middle of nowhere
this tiny company out in Scottsboro
Alabama called Unclaimed Baggage they
kind of have a monopoly on this market
where they have strict they've stricking
exclusive deals with almost every major
airline in America and they essentially
buy baggage that the airlines aren't
able to find the owner of and they sell
this baggage in a massive 40,000 square
foot warehouse and yeah you find some
pretty weird stuff there you find some
pretty weird stuff you've got like pages
and pages now they have like an online
presence so people can actually go
online and buy all kinds of things that
people have lost unbeknownst to them
their luggage is being sold out from
under them and they probably don't even
know that it is it's out there still
which is probably yeah and takes off a
lot of people but to be fair though the
so the airlines do try really hard to
reconnect the luggage with their owners
I know they they have all these crazy
matching software systems they use and
in the end only a tiny fraction of
baggage isn't actually able to be
reconnected with with its owner I think
it's something like point three percent
of all luggage in America but you know
understandably you know it is kind of a
contentious thing too because they're
they're selling really personalized
from people suitcases and they have a
process when a suitcase comes into the
store they have a team that kind of goes
through it and filters out anything that
might be inappropriate or that they
can't resell so they actually only end
up selling about a third of the stuff
that is in these suitcases the other
two-thirds either gets thrown out or
donated so don't don't tell us
everything but give us a little teaser
of some of the crazy things that that
this this company has found and sold
yeah you wouldn't believe it I mean they
you know a suit of armor $64,000 Rolex
watch it was like incredibly rare tons
of really expensive jul 23 sinja larrya
that people just never claimed that
compact frogs in a suitcase the original
original prop of the character hoggle
from the movie labyrinth which is like
this weird goblin character or whatever
it is probably get slammed in the
comments for getting that wrong
live rattlesnakes in a duffel bag all
kinds of very weird stuff that we'll get
into in the article very cool no there's
also weapons and all kinds of stuff like
NASA products and yeah so yeah they not
only sell suitcases but they sell they
buy unclaimed cargo which can be
anything like Freight cargo can be
government property and you know stuff
also stuff that's left in the overhead
bins musical instruments skis surfboards
really anything anything that people fly
with is very hand for themselves and is
the stuff reasonably priced and we
looked online is to get a sense of what
what they're selling you what they sell
oh that yeah I think you know some
customers have claimed that things are
anywhere from like 20 to 80% below what
you would pay somewhere else and it
seemed you know from glancing at their
their online inventory it seems their
prices are pretty fair I think the real
value out is you just you find one-off
things that are probably pretty hard to
find sometimes like
that $64,000 watch I mentioned you know
I think some some gentleman actually
came in the store and ended up getting
it for 35 grams so he he got a pretty
sweet deal on that watch it was probably
a you know it's a rare Rolex that he
probably couldn't find anywhere else so
it's kind of like eBay in a sense that
you you get these really strange unique
one-off items that you can't really sell
anywhere else it's kind of like kind of
like the world's best you know pawn shop
or some tank without the bonding that's
great well it's a another little
subculture that you dive into that I
can't wait to share with readers so make
sure you guys open it up on Sunday
thanks for joining the sack yeah see you
guys on Sunday
[Music]